c'est dans un écart rurale d eau d
aviron que nous découvrons la rue paul
hermann des maisons résidentielles
séparés par des parcelles en culture une
illustration parfaite du mitage une
caractéristique de la géographie locale
paul hermann y est il pour quelque chose
c'est qu'ils s'étaient collar man
quelqu'un qui vivait dans le coin qui
est née juste en solitaire au traité
nous affirmons chez des jeunes ont connu
c était un ancien instituteur c'était un
poète un écrivain c'était les abeilles
sa passion la route là était une route
tout en terre et je fais pas mal de
livres au 6e tout le patrimoine du
tévelave j'étais tout petit quand j'ai
appris que ça plaît à vous l'avez la rue
paul hermann
si les travaux de jules hermann le savon
le visionnaire l'écrivain a laissé non
seulement une trace mais surtout une
histoire de la réunion son cousin paul
instituteur marquera une génération
d'écoliers
honnête homme et scientifique on lui
doit en effet une des premières
géographie de la réunion à l'usagé des
écoliers
pour hippolyte foucque alors président
de l'académie de la réunion paul hermann
aura été une âme haute
ce saint pierrois né le 25 juillet 1878
fait partie de ces pionniers de
l'instruction de masse un instituteur
républicain à la pagnol
parmi ses nombreux travaux scientifiques
et littéraires cette histoire et
géographie de la réunion pour les cours
moyens
pour mieux atteindre l'intelligence
enfantine il y parle de l'âge du
chouchou et de l'âge de la canne à sucre
et ainsi de suite
mais il est avant tout un enseignant sa
carrière conduira cet ancien élève de
l'école normale successivement à sainte
marie à saint denis à hell bourg et aux
avirons où il sera directeur de l'école
des garçons
décoré de la croix de la légion
d'honneur de la médaille d'argent des
instituteurs et des palmes académiques
il restera simple
après une carrière bien remplie à
l'image de pagnol il se retirera au
tévelave pour s'adonner à l'apiculture
paul hermann est décédé le 2 novembre
1950 aux avirons